Pop quiz, hotshot-- you've got
48 milliseconds of work to do,
but only 16 milliseconds
per frame to get it done.
What do you do?
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And while threading on Android
can help cure your performance
woes, it can also end up
creating some huge problems,
if you don't understand how
it's all working under the hood.
So let's take a few minutes
and make sure we're all
on the same page.
See, a thread, by default,
does three things.
It starts.
It does some works, and
this is that work is done,
it terminates.
Now, by itself,
that's not too useful.
Instead, what you want is
a thread that sticks around
for a while, so you can feed it
packets of work to operate on.
But to do that, you need
a little more scaffolding.
First, since threads die
when they run out of work,
you need to have some sort
of loop running on the thread
to keep it alive.
Just make sure to put
in an exit condition
so you can terminate
that loop later.
In addition, you'll
need some sort of queue
that the loop can pull blocks
of work from to execute on.
And, of course, you'll
need some other thread
that creates work
packets and pushes them
into the queue for execution.
Now, if you've ever tried
to write the setup yourself,
you know gets a
little gnarly to get
all of that machine
reworking incorrectly.
Thankfully, though,
Android has a set
of classes to do
all that for you.
For example, the
Looper class will
keep the thread alive and pop
work off a queue to execute on.
And rather than always inserting
work at the end of that queue,
the Handler class
gives you the control
to push work at
the head, the tail,
or set a time-based
delay that'll
keep some work for
being processed
until that time has passed.
And don't forget the
units of work in Android
are explicitly defined
as intents or runables
or messages, depending
on who's issuing them
and who's consuming them.
And then the combination
of all these things
together is called
a HandlerThread,
which lets this look like this.
[CHEERING]
Pretty nifty, huh?
So let's look at how you can
use this in your application.
When the user launches
your app, Android
creates its own Linux process.
Alongside with this,
the system creates
a thread of execution
for your application
called the Main thread,
which, at its core,
is just a Handler thread.
This Main thread handles
processing of events
from all over your
app, for example,
callbacks associated with life
cycle information or callbacks
from input events,
or even events
that are coming from
other applications.
And most important is that
these callbacks can trigger
other work that
runs on the thread,
too, like making
a change to the UI
will create work packets that
allow the UI to be redrawn.
Basically, this means that
any block of code to your app
wants to run has to be
pushed into a work queue
and then serviced
on the Main thread.
The takeaway here is that
with so much work happening
on the Main thread, it
makes a lot of sense
to offload longer
work to other threads,
as to not disturb the UI system
from its rendering duties.
And this is how the entirety
of Android's threading model
works, lots of packages of
work being passed around
between threads and
worked on as needed.
So with all this in mind, some
of Android's threading classes
make a little bit more sense.
See, each threaded
class is intended
for a specific type
of threading work,
so picking the right one for
your needs is really important.
For example, the
AsyncTask class is
ideal for helping you get
work on and off the UI
thread in the right way.
HandlerThreads
are great when you
need a dedicated thread
for callbacks to land on.
And ThreadPools work best when
you could break your work up
into really small packets
and then toss them
to a bunch of waiting threads.
And IntentServices are really
ideal for background task
or when you need to get
intent work off the UI thread.
And like everything
else, there's
not a silver bullet here.
But knowing which primitive
is best for what situation,
can save you a lot of headaches.
Now, if you ever want more
insight into how your app is
leveraging threading, make sure
you spend some time getting
comfortable with Systrace.
It's a fancy tool
that'll school you
on how all that mumbo jumbo is
working underneath the hood.
And if you're looking
to get schooled more,
make sure you check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for more tips
and tricks on threading.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.